there's nothing controversial about
Black History Month it is an American
idea that has been imported but I have
always tried to make sure that it
emphasizes British black history and
stories that people might not have known
but always sticking to riger you get
lots of weird things where people will
say that somebody was actually really
black when they're not just a historical
sort of nonsense I think you see some of
that creeping into black history month
we shouldn't be having that it should be
accurate stories about black British
history the truth is black history if
you're being very literal is African
history of which very little is ever
told kings and queens of Africa
dictators rulers what happened history
of Communism and how it shaped a lot of
policy in the continent how that
influences nobody talks about that I see
even Primary School it's quite often
Rosa Parks some Martin Luther King but
it is more political than it should be
you should depoliticize black history
month and I think too many people use it
as a political tool